[Music]
devin joins us in wichita devon welcome
to the ramsay show
hi how are you guys doing today great
how can john and i help
i just had a question about
the feeling of resentment towards my
step brother and his girlfriend when
they finance cool items and me and my
wife gave up over time for those same
items hey can you uh devin talk in
directly into your phone there for me
sorry about that there we go there you
go okay say that again so you have
resentment towards your brother and your
sister-in-law because they're financing
things and you save up for things and
paying cash
yes him and his girlfriend are they
financing things through your bank
account
no just it's the idea that they have
cool items now when you my wife are
saving up over time for those cooler
items later on uh what's a cool item
well they just bought a house and
they're both 22 and we're still saving
up for a down payment and i know that
they
they uh loaned a down payment so it's
technically not a down payment but
so now i talked about getting cool cars
and whatnot so a few weeks ago so one
cool thing about working at ramsey is
there's a lot of people have
like this is like a sugar addict's
nightmare there's lots of bowls of candy
around this place
um and so i grabbed a handful on the way
out from somebody's desk and
i took it home to my kids
i've got a 11 almost 12 year old and a
six-year-old
and
my six-year-old is allergic to peanuts
and things and so i gave my 11 my 11
year old several pieces of candy
and all i had for
my six-year-old was just a little bit so
i gave it to her
and she's six
and she said
but you gave him you gave hank this
stuff i said yeah i know and i brought
you this
i'm trying to keep you alive
trying to keep you from from being dead
and in her six-year-old sweet little
mind there was this great injustice that
had just happened
and i tell you this because she was six
six
as a country we have decided that we
don't let her vote or buy guns or drink
beer because she's sick
so
fast forward to you brother devin
what why is this getting into you so
much you and your wife are working hard
you're doing right you're trying not to
end up on the side of the road which is
where your
other family members are clearly going
to end up like why is this getting in
your soul so much because you're not six
well
we've we both grew up in families where
financing was just a normal situation
okay um so we've always grew up around
nicer cars or finance cars so they were
always you know a year maybe two years
um from new
and uh ever since i took your guys
course in high school and
ever since we got married last year
uh we've been living we've never been in
debt before me and her so we've never
had any kind of loans or nothing so
it's always been saving up and saving up
always takes longer than you know it's
easy to just go finance something so
seeing we're really close to my step
brother and his girlfriend
so we're constantly hanging out with
them and whenever we go over to their
house and they start talking about how
they're going to go
here in a couple months they're wanting
to go buy a brand new jeep for his
girlfriend and whatnot you know it
sounds awesome and i know that when we
leave their house we're going well you
know looks pretty stupid that they're
doing that
it's still that feeling of that you know
they're gonna have it though and that's
it's pretty cool so it's just weird
devin have you heard this quote from
carrie fisher resentment is like
drinking poison and waiting for the
other person to die
that's what's happening right now
you're on a different journey if you
didn't know your brother you'd have no
clue if he had a paid for house and a
paid for car or if he was drowning in
debt
so when i pull up to someone at the
stoplight my honda civic it's an 09 with
body damage and the guy next to me is
driving a brand new tesla i don't know
his financial situation he doesn't know
mine he doesn't know i have a paid for
house and have no debt and it doesn't
matter you could say that's a really rad
car and i do i say man it'd be nice to
have a tesla but i don't have the money
and then
i'm on with my day
here here's the here's the i wanna we're
i'm poking at you devon but here's the
here's the honest truth we do get this
call a lot and we have this conversation
a lot
people make this journey all about the
numbers the dollars and cents the
savings the things we're giving up
and if you do that
your your identity ends up in ash
because everything in your life is about
the stuff we don't have so the challenge
moving forward for you is to flip the
entire way you're looking at this around
you found an incredible partner you
found a great wife that is on the same
page with you
spiritually psychologically financially
y'all are working towards something and
it's hard
and yes it's cool to ride in a rad jeep
it is you know it's not cool when they
tow it away because i can't afford it or
because they broke up
it's super cool to live in a fancy house
it is not cool to be pacing the house
because you don't know how you're gonna
pay your bills and i've been there i've
done that
where my wife's asleep and i can't
breathe i'm about to throw up and it's
two o'clock in the morning because i
don't know how we're gonna pay our bills
and so i want you to flip this thing
around and not look at the debt-free
journey as an adventure and crap you
don't have
but i want you to flip it around and say
we are on the adventure of a lifetime to
make sure that nobody in devon's family
tree ever deals with this stuff again
you see what i'm saying
yes it's an enti
it's an entire identity shift your
actions day to day will actually be very
similar you're not going to borrow money
you're going to keep saving for things
you're going to pay stuff off as it
comes right you're going to keep doing
the same things but why you're doing it
is so different
not because we're just not going to have
stuff but because we are making it stops
with us those people who think they're
better because they drive fancy cars
they can't afford who live in houses
they can't afford who co-sign on things
with their girlfriends which is just a
disaster you get what i'm saying devin
well here's what i want to do devin i
want to send you a copy of rachel cruz's
book love your life not theirs
because this what this comes down to is
comparisons and you're going well i'm
not where they are dude you're way ahead
it just looks different yeah because
you're looking at things that aren't
real because it's all financed they
don't own any of it and that's okay you
can still love them you can hang out
with them in their beautiful house and
ride in their nice cars you go hey man
that's your journey if you want to know
what i'm up to how i became debt-free
and how we can do all these things over
here let us know and if not that's cool
i'm still your brother yeah
it's just it's not about the shiny stuff
and this is all about an identity shift
yeah but this is a real crisis i think
for this generation especially for the
younger ones well
it's so much easier to crush our parents
too i mean that's kind of where we got
into all this it crushed our parents too
oh i can build this bigger house look
they've got two cars like i grew up we
only had one family car and then all of
a sudden was like well the neighbors got
two right so it's been this way forever
they've got that we should get that and
it's been keeping up with the joneses
right that's been forever the problem
now is the joneses are international
because we got these digital boxes so
they're ever everyone's chances you
scroll and you're like i'll never be
enough yeah i'll never amount to
anything and i used to be able to see my
neighbors two cars but then i would see
like
i don't really want their life i don't
get that and i get the curated version
so i get where devin's at i get it i get
it but man when you can make that shift
and go man
i'm so grateful that we don't have to
make any payments i'm so grateful to
have this level of contentment and where
we're at in the journey and that
sacrifice builds character yeah and that
character will carry you through the
rest of your life so there's a great
thing i learned i ran track in in high
school a little bit because
thank you for that i appreciate that um
yeah that was my lo-fi uh high school
call back flex what a flex that's right
um
but i learned often when you're
especially when you're training
not to race the people around you race
the clock you're racing you how'd you do
yesterday how are you doing today are
you meeting the goals you set up today
and it's you versus that clock man which
means it's you versus you when you're on
this financial journey it's so tempting
to look to your left and your right your
left and your right
it's about where you're headed you can't
run like usain bolt john but you can't
beat john from yesterday that's exactly
right and that is the person i'm
competing against well set